if you grew up in a house with older
siblings you got scared people you
scaring was just the lower you know the
thing you did to each other all the time
but my brother and i am a when i scare i
am a
high-pitched
jazz hander right
so i go when i and he used to love that
that made him laugh
right
but after a while wasn't enough so he
added after he scared me he would punch
me in the chest right
because it sounded like this
and he loved it
you can always hear his laugh
all right
you sound so
stupid when i got to be around 11 or 12
he decided he liked to fart in my mouth
[Applause]
and he would and he would tell me i'm
gonna fart in your mouth right now right
and what's your instinct i'm gonna i'm
gonna fight i'm gonna with every ounce
of my energy i'm [ __ ] fighting you
you're not farting in my mouth
but he was so much stronger than me i
would end up eating like 20 punches and
then a couple of farts you know what i
mean so
i started to realize i can either eat
the punches and the farts or just the
fart
i'm gonna tell you the day he stopped
farting in my mouth was he was like come
here i'm gonna fart in your mouth and i
went okay
and he goes well i'm not going to do it
if you like it you [ __ ] weirdo
i'm living [ __ ] just to make it through
another 24.
we'll have a stretch i got me constantly
smoking i'm getting high just to balance
out the lows
and they always tell me that
[Music]
another day another dollar howler 7 p.m
what's it gonna break another bug